buenos aires et sa périphérie à l'orée
d'un nouveau confinement
alors que les autorités sanitaires
argentine évoque un rebond inquiétant
des cas de couronnes un virus l'exécutif
annonce un retour à des mesures strictes
dès le 1er juillet la région la plus
peuplée du pays considérée comme la
source de contamination du reste de
l'argentine s'isolera à nouveau le
mercredi 1er juillet nous allons prendre
une mesure plus sévère
nous allons demander à tout le monde du
6 au lait à nouveau chez soi et vent
levé la salle ont fermé à nouveau la
zone métropolitaine de buenos aires de
sorte que la circulation diminue
considérablement en réduisant la
circulation nous réduirons la contagion
en réduisant la contagion nous
ralentirons l'occupation des au brésil
deuxième pays le plus touché au monde
après les états unis
ces images deviennent récurrentes le
plus grand cimetière d'amérique latine
creuse toujours plus de tombes pour
accueillir des victimes de plus en plus
nombreuses
le mexique est également en mauvaise
posture la barre des 25 mille décès liés
au virus est atteinte et l'épidémie
n'est pas terminée prévient le ministère
de la santé depuis février nous disons
préparons nous à une longue épidémie
dans ce contexte une longue épidémie
signifie qu'une fois que l'épidémie a
commencé le 28 février 2020 elle durera
au moins jusqu'en octobre 2020 selon les
prévisions mathématiques il paie intel
dans la prédiction nes mathématiques il
me soumet le glamour que oui nous avons
réussi à avoir moins de cas par jour
surtout au plus fort de la crise nous
avons réussi à déplacer la date
dupliquer à faire en sorte que personne
ne soit laissé sans surveillance parce
que l'hôpital est surchargé nous y
parvenons mais l'épidémie continue
depuis plusieurs semaines le continent
subit de plein fouet la crise sanitaire
et doit faire face à des conséquences
désastreuses dans ce combat contre le
coc vite 19